this is my favorite place on earth
the salar de uyuni in bolivia and when it
is covered with a thin layer of water
the clouds are reflected and there are days that you
feel as if you are rubbing between the
clouds but there are days that the horizon
disappears they no longer exist  and up or
down
one feels immersed in something bigger
and it was there that one night in the middle of a
dream I woke up and saw that the
stars were also reflected on the water and
this was not a dream it was as if I
could not walk on  the stars at
every step that the stars took
reverberated under my feet it was like
feeling the universe floating in the middle
of clouds of galaxies but what floats
today is not only numbers of
galaxies but also it is not plastic
and these are the traces that  we are
leaving on the planet are the marks of
an era in which the behavior of
some men is leaving a
global impact on terrestrial ecosystems
and this era is called the anthropocene there are
also  There are other types of polluting toxic clouds
that float in the air such as
those resulting from carbon dioxide emissions from
the burning of fossil fuels,
oil, coal, gas clouds
when we see them they pollute our dreams I
don't know if you but I always dreamed of
float among the clouds and today perhaps
together we can imagine another type of
clouds some clouds with which we can
live now you wonder in the
image and I must clarify it looks like a collage
of a photomontage a real thing this
is not reality but there are times that I
I ask what is reality
as alexander kluge says human beings
are interested in reality
they cannot be it is part of their human essence
they have desires these desires are
totally opposite to any form
reality they prefer to deceive themselves
before divorcing their desires but how to
learn  so float among the clouds
me as an artist so i thought we
could start building
flying museum  who wonder with
plastic bags in 2007 with a community of
people around the world we started
collecting used plastic bags they
weren't new and that's when we
gave them out we cut them we glued them we started drawing
on them big a giant canvas
we have a collection  of drawings of
personal stories and friendships and
when they come together they bend and fold
a space full of air is formed and
when the sun rises from the horizon
the museum celebrates in the sky that is why we
call it the solar museum and from this
simple idea  prizes to float in the
air in a radically new way without
using any type of fuel is
the difference in temperature between the
inside and outside is what makes us
carry so this way we do not
use fossil fuels neither
they nor hydrogen we do not use solar
panels  and batteries or motors
we find a series in a
simple and clean way
high temps everyone need for power carry  I
remember how much NASA in 2009 with 120
engineers and the likes also know when
the planes sound these
control panels are gigantic and the complexity
we are having is very great
when the plastic bags arrived
we cannot get there any other way people are
still  difficult to understand and
seeing this strength of this idea
we began to improve a new era that would
leave behind the violence of the
Anthropocene to enter a new era
in which we call it the sinus ring an
era of ecological awareness in which
we learn to float together live in
the air and reach an ethical commitment
with the atmosphere and with the planet
earth that is why behind this backpack today there will be
this is a balloon that we also
call ourselves a sculpture and if tomorrow it
is sunny we can go out to fly
what yes in vancouver on  time is not
very very favorable
well what else does someone have even a
few sensors that when it moves
as well as the drawings in the air and t  It also
has other sensors,
I always think it is first you have to feel
and then we can measure it to feel
the sounds of the atmosphere of the climate
of the hot air and then be able to
measure it the carbon dioxide sounded
sensors that we are developing together
with different communities around the
world to reconnect  with the climate the
temperature and the environment because
there are other species in the air because in
these excursions into the atmosphere we
are not alone the air is full of
clouds of life lived at the bottom of an
ocean of air and this same sculpture
these are not another  that is in my hands for
the 600 km 12 hours of germany poland
on a trip fuel book but
not free crossing borders
a trip much more complicated than
we can imagine the air space
is as regulated and militarized as the
land sail with the winds  with the
heat of the sun and the radiation of the
earth it is complex and beautiful but
it will be even more complex  permission to
cross the airspaces of each
of the countries that we navigate with the
winds during the climate change summit
cop with iván in paris we
present these spherical cultures that
could transport us around the
world
but how can we be moved by the
wind to reach  our destiny
together with the motto haiti we have
developed a program that predicts
how we can navigate the highways of
the winds
for example if I had to return
from vancouver to berlin
the first thing I have to do is choose
a height different heights different
directions and speed is the  red line
is tomorrow the orange day after and there it goes
as we see the best day to return to
berlin and there we are traveling
with the winds it is in six days and
we reach 170 kilometers from the center of
berlin without burning a drop of
fuel only transported by
currents  of the winds is so we
think that these trajectories that
we draw with the wind can  of
becoming signatures to declare a
day of independence from
fossil fuels
more and more of us are feeling
the air in a different
way just as you know the day of the
earth we think we can celebrate the day
of the air
a pact we make with the  earth an
ethical commitment to the atmosphere
but let's keep thinking and dreaming we have
learned that the bigger the sculptures are the
more weight they can lift
remember that they are carried only by hot air
that is heated by the sun and in
this way we can learn to build
gardens in  the air
we will one day be able to live in a garden
the size of the earth
we will be able to live in an ecosystem floating
in the clouds answering these
questions is not only a
technological challenge, it is a way of re-examining
the freedom of movement between
countries and of overcoming
political social cultural and
military restrictions of contemporary societies
because in the last place
the air belongs to everyone and it does not depend on
any sovereignty
as we said before the imagination the
force that can lead us to create
these places
this is an installation that the
new york metropolitan museum reviews in
which we speculate how it could make
these transnational spaces and  once
we inhabit these places we must
learn to move in them to walk
among the clouds where each movement
affects the way others move
the weight of the body and the closeness
between people causes space to
expand or contract and there we are
suspended at a height of 22 meters and
when two or more people get
too close even the most distant people
end up more affected everyone is going
to the same place
these are fragile ecosystems and it is
between these spheres where we
build networks that connect us there are
moments when  we face emptiness
and fear cannot paralyze one of the
most beautiful things this installation in the
sol  ida that is generated when we
face these new airbrushes
to finish
let me tell you one last story on
july 16, 1905 the white dunes of
new mexico the first
detonation of an atomic bomb took place as a
result of this explosion and a cloud of
radioactive particles was  they
spread throughout the earth marking the beginning
of the Anthropocene 70 years later on
November 8, 2015
in the same place another event occurred for the
first time in history
we were able to raise a person in the air
only with the action of the sun without
burning any  fossil fuel
as the sun rose over the
horizon we also
rose silently and slowly without
exclusions and we felt as if
gravity was reversed it
no longer takes us towards the cent of the
earth but towards the universe and points
showed when it stepped on  the moon said
one small step for man one giant
leap for humanity
maybe what we have to ask ourselves
what are  With the steps and steps we have to take
today in the age of
aero sine our steps are much
smaller but radically different
steps that started with a bag full
of air and desires but cannot
lead to independence from
fossil fuels for  being able to celebrate
air day steps that do not leave
traces on other planets until we
have learned to walk in the
atmosphere of this are the
minimum landscapes and some minimum steps but I hope
that we can all walk it together and
I am sure that these steps will not go  to
take much further than the moon and so
we can learn to float with our feet
on the ground
thanks
[Applause]